Hello Freak bitches,
dude.
I just had a Twitter argument
with Chelsea Clinton last night.
It's like these people don't understand,
never respond to someone who's
like way less than a year.
You know,
she like,
I called her basically,
I called her parents war
criminals and she was like,
yeah,
you know,
I should have listened more during,
during the 2003 war,
Iraq war two,
they antiwar activist,
but she,
she initially called people
who were protesting the
Afghanistan war and like the
AUMF anti American.
And so she was like,
yeah,
because there was a story that came out
that said Chelsea Clinton actually with
like American flags and all these things
like when and disrupted an antiwar
protest flat after nine 11.
Yeah.
Like a group of like patriots
including Cold Joshi,
Quinn props like 22 or something.
I mean,
I don't know,
maybe,
maybe younger.
Um,
so then people were calling
her out and being like,
you know,
like mother like daughter,
cause there's stories of Hillary Clinton,
like really working hard
to quell the protest,
the Vietnam war protests on campus and
stuff as the president of the dump.
The Republican Young Republicans club.
She was the president.
Really?
Yeah.
It's just pre or post Kent state this.
Ooh,
good question.
Really good question.
I don't know.
It was when the whole,
it'd be hard to defend it after that.
Right after people are shot.
But yeah,
so Chelsea actually responded to me.
I was floored because I was like,
your dad killed 500,000 babies in Iraq
with the sanctions and your mom voted for
the Iraq war.
I was like,
why don't you protest them?
And she was like,
you know,
I was like,
what?
She just said,
she was like,
you know,
I wasn't really,
she was,
I don't think that people
protest in the Afghanistan war,
anti American.
And she was like,
you know,
140 characters limiting.
I was like,
do you see that I just called your
parents war criminals and you're actually
responding to whatever,
whatever WTF.
Just put the blinders on.
Oh my God.
And then she was like,
I was talking about the Americans who
denounce like you know that America a an
imperialist warmonger I was like,
it is the country's imperialist
warmongering country
that's killed millions of
people.
You serve the democratic processes of
dozens of countries and the world actually
thinks that America is the number
one threat to global peace.
So I actually agree with the Americans.
You denounce Chelsea,
it was nuts.
So that was a highlight of the day.
Yeah,
that's not a good look for her.
No,
she should probably stay
off Twitter for a few years.
Yeah,
she's,
it's like dude,
just,
just step back.
I mean you sound awful.
I know that you're trying to
get in the public spotlight and,
and get that momentum behind you.
I mean people are already talking
about her running in 2020 yeah.
Michelle Obama.
Chelsea Clinton.
Yeah.
You imagine what they are finding is
that there's like two parts of our
operating brain,
and this is going to be me paring it down,
but one is the analytical thinking,
deciding thing.
And the other is this
social awareness sprain,
which is always like always checking
in on how am I in relation to others.
It's also the part of that
brain that actually we can,
you know,
like the metacognitive part
and the part that I can,
they call it mind reading,
but really it's just,
it's just by US sitting here,
I can kind of get a sense of how you
feel and what you're thinking right.
Just by the,
the connection that we have and just,
it's part of who we are.
So when our analytical brain is offline,
this other one,
the social one pops on immediately.
So,
so what they're theorizing is that that
is like the fundamental need for humans
in safety and survival is how are
we relating to each other as a,
as a group.
But it makes sense if you look,
I mean to me it makes sense in,
um,
you know,
we are social animals.
We forget that,
I think,
but you look at other species of
monkeys or wolves or whatever,
I mean,
you know,
there might be a period of time where say,
Oh,
a wolf will will get kicked out of a pack
for awhile and he'll go do his thing,
but eventually come back to a pack.
It's not safe for us
as humans and animals,
social animals like these to be isolated.
It's,
it's not.
And,
and so there's all these
parts of us that just,
if we're not connected
to other people in a,
in a very direct and true way,
there's these sort of a deep down,
emotional and physiological,
uh,
fears that come up,
right?
And they,
and they're the real,
and that's what the
neurobiology is showing,
which is really an interesting and mean.
We can just think about that,
but they're actually showing it now that
if we're not really connected to each
other,
we're going to be freaked out.
We're not going to be okay.
And,
um,
you know,
I really believe that this really drives
a lot of the internal struggle we have.
And we're really,
and this is part of,
you know,
getting into it,
but that's part of my,
what I'm trying to bring into
the world and my platform now is,
is just to,
you know,
stand up and say,
hey,
we need each other and we can do it.
It's not,
and for guys specifically,
right?
It's such a social stigma of ours to
not be real or open or connected or
vulnerable with guys.
And uh,
and it's,
uh,
it's cool to see the science
coming out because it's,
I've all this anecdotal evidence of being
out the woods in the woods with kids
or being in a,
in a management with guys are running
a retreat or whatever this is of how
powerful it is to like set down all
of our differences and just be there.
But now the science is really
lightened it up and yeah,
man,
loneliest.
I mean,
we can all think about
a loneliness isn't fun.
It's not a,
it doesn't feel good.
But the other,
this is crazy too that they're showing
that emotional pain lights up the same
centers of our brain.
It's physical pain.
And that the one study showed that,
um,
an insult to someone had much more
painful and longterm effects than slamming
somebody with a hammer,
hitting their hand with a hammer.
So like our emotional pain literally
actually exists in the body.
Like it is actual pain and the
reason that it's so uncomfortable
to feel our emotions,
which it is,
you know,
I mean I'll just say it is,
is that it actually hurts
like actually hurts.
I mean and there's like people say things
like you broke my heart or I'm dying
of heart ache or whatever,
but the science is catching up and
showing us that this pain is actual,
it's real.
Um,
I know you're really interested
in this and I am too.
And um,
the,
there are some misconceptions and that,
well I shouldn't say their misconceptions.
I would say that there's a
distortion of what's going on.
And this is not to say it's,
it's actually to say that it's
worse than you think it is.
So what most people who are outside of
academia think is going on is not quite
what's going on.
We think it's something worse.
Well,
I know,
cause I've heard you and lots and
lots of other people talk about it.
And it's not your fault at all because
you're not there and all you do is get
the media reports about it.
So I think what most people,
I get it from Gad sad and
Jordan Peterson or professors,
they end day.
If you listen to them,
actually they will,
they themselves,
we'll talk about it a little differently,
but people still consume it differently.
Cause the news right is all about the
crazy thing that the 18 year old said
right at Wesleyan or whatever
or the not the 18 year old,
it's the 45 year olds and then
sometimes the 45 year old.
Yeah,
okay.
But here's the,
so that stuff that really
sort of loony stuff,
you know,
that you hear coming out or um,
protests,
you know,
people saying that they are going
to die because you said a word.
Um,
that happens.
It does.
It's all true.
It's all there.
I've seen it,
but I've seen it maybe at most one time
a year in the colleges where I've been.
Maybe not even less than that.
Okay.
What is,
and if it were just that,
that's not actually a big deal.
It's much worse than that.
What's,
what's worse is that if there is a self
censorship going on that's universal and
profound,
constant,
omnipresent.
Like for instance,
you know,
I never talk about my love for boxing
around academics or I'm very careful if I
do,
but it's not even that.
It's that we know that there are certain
things that can't be set on a college
campus and so we just don't say them.
Therefore there's no need to police us.
There's no need to yell at us
and scream at us and protest.
And what's the motivation for the for
which are the people that are holding back
on thoughts that maybe they would
normally express because they don't?
Well,
here's what I think it is for the
senior faculty who have tenure,
meaning lifetime appointments,
cowardice.
That's all it is.
I think they're cowards.
Yeah.
If you are an adjunct like me with no
job security or if you're an assistant
professor up for tenure and
if you don't get tenure,
you have no career.
I don't blame them.
I get it.
That's what I've done too.
I police myself cause you
have to to stay in the game.
If you have tenure,
lifetime appointment,
your senior professor,
you make the decisions
there on curriculum,
hiring and firing and tenure.
The faculty make those decisions and
you don't challenge these crazy ideas in
any way.
Or if you police yourself,
you stop yourself from
saying things that you,
you think are right that you believe in.
You're a coward.
I'm sorry.
Those people are cowards.
I've seen it.
It's just overrun by cowards.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
No,
I mean this,
they are very though.
So here's the thing,
I can't prove this.
This is just so,
I'm just saying this is,
this is my belief,
but I think it's pretty well informed
cause I've been around these people a long
time and in part I share this the,
I think the worst fear of all those people
is being called a racist or a sexist
publicly.
I think that is their
version of being in a cave,
crawling on their bellies
in the pitch black.
I think that's their worst fear.
[inaudible]
okay.